Film Courage: Please correct me if I’m wrong
but was ALL THE PRESIDENT’S MEN an adaptation?
Woodward and Bernstein’s book?
Dr. Ken Atchity, Producer/Author: Yes.
Film Courage: I just remember in so many scenes
they were running.
Can you talk about the script in any way?
Ken: You know, I’m not as familiar with
the script as I’d like to be because I’d
like to have recently read the book and the
script.
One of the things you do in a story like that
is you add the running because there probably
is not a lot of running in real life.
I mean these journalists are probably too
heavy to be running in real life.
Film Courage: They may not look like Robert
Redford either?
Ken: Some of them might but that’s the big
challenge.
Like SPOTLIGHT is an example.
They took a lot of, lot of reporting from
Boston Globe and turned it into a dramatic
movie that covered…that collapsed many years
into a few years.
You have to take those liberties and that’s
why you end up saying ‘Inspired by a true
story’ instead of ‘Based on a true story,’
etc.
I’ve been through that many times.
But adding action and adding drama is what
you have to do.
Film Courage: Right and the scene in SPOTLIGHT
where Stanely Tucci, you don’t see him yet
but you hear him yelling at his assistant
and I think something is thrown and then the
look on Mark Ruffalo’s face [who is waiting
to see him] and that right there is enough
to set the stakes.
Ken: Right, exactly.
It’s good drama.
It involves the audience immediately because
you don’t see what’s happening, so you
see a reaction to what’s happening so you
have to figure out what’s happening.
And one of the common mistakes that younger
writers make is that they patronize the audience
by explaining too much, by thinking that every
single thing has to be there.
And I always say when you’re editing, one
of the top 10 rules of editing are all the
same…cut…cut…cut…cut…cut.
Because when you’re in doubt about whether
you need something, that alone is a reason
for cutting it.
You don’t need it.
The audience will make the jump and fill in
the blanks.
And if you don’t let them fill in the blanks
(it’s called painting-by-the-numbers) then
you come across as patronizing to the audience
and they get bored.
They don’t want to hear every detail.
You don’t have to say “Your Honor” in
the court scene every single sentence.
You don’t have to say the character’s
name every time you talk to the character.
People get this out of their system after
10 years of writing, but at the beginning,
you don’t know where the lines are.
And sense of the audience.
One of the things I like to talk about is
the psychology of the audience.
It’s not the psychology of the author that
makes you read a book, you don’t care about
that.
It’s just like your listening to your friend
talking about his latest bout in the hospital.
I mean how much do you care about how he felt
about every little thing?
You care as long as you can, but if he has
any sense at all he’ll cut it down.
And the truth is you don’t care about the
psychology of the characters either.
That’s not what’s important, what’s
important is your psychology as always, the
audience’s psychology.
And that’s why Hitchcock and Peter Weir
really know what they’re doing.
That drive away in WITNESS is one of the most
brilliant parts of the film because of the
length of the driveway.
So it was the location choice.
He’s telling the location manager I need
a place that has a long, long, long, driveway
that will give me a 60-second tracking shot.
And in THE BIRDS when the heroine takes the
flashlight without even testing whether it
works or not and starts heading up the wooden
steps because she hears rustling in the attic,
that is the longest walk up the steps you’ve
ever seen in a film because it is so stupid
that the audience needs at least three or
four steps to get it out of their system.
Oh c’mon why does every actress, and why
does she have to have white underwear on,
and why is it always at the end of a horror
film, and why doesn’t she test it…so once
you get past that…okay now she’s on the
middle step…and then you go through “Oh,
my God, why is she…this doesn’t make any
sense…I don’t want to go through this.
This doesn’t make any sense.
And then by the time she gets to the top step…you’re
ready, like okay, I paid to get scared, this
is it.
And that is using the psychology of audience,
that’s the timing that the audience needs
to get into the exact right mood.
It’s just like the speech in JULIUS CESAR
where Marc Anthony comes up after Brutus’s
brilliant speech on the corpse of Julius Cesar.
And Anthony praises Brutus’s speech and
calls him the honorable Brutus and by the
end of his speech he’s turned the entire
crowd against Brutus even though they were
all cheering for Brutus at the beginning of
his speech.
He takes the psychology of the audience and
twists it around in a way that you can see
it coming but you don’t care, you just want
to go there.
And nobody cares about Anthony’s psychology
and nobody cares about Brutus’s psychology
(that’s not important) and nobody cares
about Shakespeare’s psychology because nobody
knows that his psychology is.
They said the greatness of Shakespeare and
Homer is that they themselves were nowhere
to be found in their work, their characters
were everywhere.
And the characters speak directly to the audience.
That’s the hardest thing about writing is
figuring that out.